and that's why I can't be queen of just
auradon I have to be queen of the Isle -
we love you mal but we have something to
confess we don't think you should be the
queen of both auradon and the isle
clearly you're wet or Don needs you and
then help change or it on for the better
and the world loves you for it but OMA
has what it takes to be a ruler - and
she should have become the queen of the
isle at the end of descendants three Ben
and Mel are taking auradon by storm and
it'll never be the same again but that
isn't exactly a bad thing uma and mal
both have what it takes to lead a nation
but unfortunately for uma the Isle of
the Lost slipped through her fingers
keep watching to find out why uma truly
deserved to be crowned queen of the Isle
that was my home someone needs to be
there to protect it now is the queen
that auradon needed she changed things
for the better but risked her morals in
the process at the end of d3 mal tells
her future kingdom that she can't be
their queen she tells them that she
can't turn her back on the Isle and
that's why I can't be queen of just
auradon I have to be queen of the aisle
- her touching speech leads to the
barrier being taken down and turns her
into the queen of not one but two
different kingdoms we love how mal had a
change of heart and did what was right
for everyone but it did take her a long
time to make the right decision uma on
the other hand has always done what was
best for her people and not herself
before we reveal why Huma is the Isles
rightful Queen let's tackle the many
reasons why mouths should have given
Emma at the title when Malin Ben found
out that Maleficent sceptre and the
Queen's crown had been stolen from the
museum he automatically blamed the V
Ches
Belle asked mal what she thought they
should do and now confess that there was
only one way to keep evil out of worry
Don I think that we have to close the
barrier forever instead of fighting for
her people mal pulled the plug without
checking her facts she was ready to
condemn the people of the Isle to a
lifetime of imprisonment
which isn't something a queen would do
mal didn't fight for the Isle
didn't ask for more time to team instead
she suggested the barrier be closed down
for good and just when we thought things
couldn't get any worse
Mao lied to her best friends she told
Eevee that fen and his parents were
thinking of closing down the barrier
forever when in reality it was per idea
mal even lied to squeaky squirmy Celia
and dizzy
telling them that they could go back to
visit their parents whenever they wanted
when she knew full well that they could
never go back as the future Queen
aborted on mal had the opportunity to
fight for the aisle and be heard but
instead she chose to protect the people
of auradon and turned her back on her
hometown mal even promised to free
everyone on the aisle to get Emma and
her pirates to help her save auradon
from Audrey you can take the girl out of
the aisle but you can't take the aisle
out of the girl if there's one person
who has never stopped fighting for the
aisle its uma the sea witch escaped from
the aisle at the end of descendants two
but she never turned her back on it
instead she tried to find ways to free
her people who must circled the barrier
on ek day waiting for the perfect moment
to strike once the barrier was closed
uma stole Hades ember from mal and used
it as a bargaining chip guarantee me
that every single villian kid who wants
to can get off the isle she offered to
help the BK save word on in exchange for
the Isles freedom this is a job for
pirate yeah we can always go back to
hating each other when this is over and
now agreed working with your enemy isn't
easy but uma was willing to put their
differences aside to save her people no
one was more disappointed than uma when
mal revealed her web of lies Puma and
hook left Mau to fend for herself but
Emma just couldn't bear to see mal and
Celia get hurt so she swallowed her
pride and helped Mouse a Bourdon knowing
full well that she'd be stuck on the
aisle
uma chose to help mal save word on
despite having been lied to and
manipulated but what's even more
impressive is that Numa chose to go back
to the Isle once all was said and done
although she could have run for the
hills
left the aisle behind boomin knew that
the vks needed a ruler that was my home
someone needs to be there to protect it
she went back because she knew that the
kids needed her she sacrificed
everything for her people and it didn't
go unnoticed when mouth finally made the
decision to bring down the barrier we
saw a beautifully dressed Dumas standing
on a podium and it looked like uma had
already become the queen of the Isle so
we felt super bad for her when Mao
claimed the title for herself but Huma
wasn't about to fight for the crown
because she's not a selfish person
uma was super happy to see her people
walk free
she knew they'd have more opportunities
than ever before so she wasn't about to
throw everything out the window for a
crown is it just us or does Emma have
what it takes to be a wonderful ruler it
would have been nice to see you uma Ben
and mal ruling side by side but we're
sure mal will involve uma when it comes
to making decisions for the aisle or at
least we hope so so who do you think
should be the queen of the aisle mouth
or uma sound off in the comments hit
that subscribe button and give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching we'll catch you next time on
the things
[Music]